[موسيقى]
كلنا بنعاني من الارق والتراب النوم بسبب
اضطراب الساعه البيولوجيه في رمضان وده
مرتبط بالسلوكيات الدينيه والسلوكات
الاجتماعيه في شهر رمضان النهارده انا
معكم عشان نحاول ندي بعض الارشادات
والنصائح اللي تساعدنا جميعا ان احنا ازاي
نحسن كفاءه النوم بتاعنا في رمضان اولا ان
احنا بنحاول اثناء الصيام ان احنا في بعد
العصر او بعد الظهر بناخد قيلوله قصيره
عشان تمنعنا من الاجهاد ونقدر نوصل اليوم
مع السهر في شهر رمضان بتقول ان القيلوله
دي بتكون في حدود من 30 دقيقه مكسيما ب 45
دقيقه
في رمضان بعد الفطار بنحاول مع الفطار ان
احنا ناخد وجبات خفيفه
نتجنب الافراط في الشاي في المنبهات
تحتوي على الكافيين او النيكوتين او
مشروبات الطاقه طبعا اكيد كلنا بنشرب قهوه
بعد الفطار ده شيء طبيعي بس الاكثار
والافراط فيها وده طبعا مش مستحب يفضل مره
او مرتين ماكسيما
يفضل ان احنا نمارس رياضه خفيفه قبل
الفطار او بعد الفطار نتجنب تماما
الرياضات العنيفه في الفتره اللي قبل
النوم مع الاقل بثلاث ساعات نحاول ان احنا
بعد صلاه التراويح او على الساعه عشره 11
ان احنا نحاول ان احنا ندخل ننام
طبعا مش هناخد معنا اي اجهزه الكترونيه زي
الموبايل التابلتس نحاول ننام في غرفه
تكون اضافه فيها خافته جدا او مظلمه لو
احنا نقدر نعمل كده
ونحاول نصحى على السحور في السحور نتجنب
تماما اكلات المشبعه بالدهون او بالسكريات
العاليه بناخد سحور خفيف نشرب ميه كتير
لان الميه بتساعدنا ان احنا نتجنب الاجهاد
وبالتالي الشعور بالنعاس طول اليوم وبعد
السحور نستنى شويه قبل ما ندخل السرير
ثاني ان احنا نحاول نصلي الفجر ونقعد شويه
وندخل ننام ساعه او ساعتين قبل ما نروح
الدوام بتاعنا
[موسيقى]